somewhere between when were a baby and
when we're a fully functioning member of
society we come to reach a decision
about what we're capable of when I go
around the world asking the question
who's a great leader people bring up
names from Gandhi great political
leaders in history JFK and the like the
ones who come to mind when you think
about people you admire is that they are
known for continuing their development
throughout their lives
clearly there's a developmental process
and yet at some point we come to the
conclusion that there are some things we
can do and some things we can't do these
exceptional leaders were not born
exceptional and they didn't know a thing
they became something over their life
and the question is can you become
something over your life write down
something you want to do to develop
yourself personally in terms of
development and growth mindset write
down something that you would like to do
that would make you better at affecting
others in your organization that way
creating a context for others to
flourish and write down a change that
you could make in yourself that you
think would impact the broader
environment make them your personal
commitment to develop yourself at all
three of these levels transform your
approach to leadership excellence and
development learn more about SCP the
Stanford executive program